[Music]
so a little bit about me um had of a
plaat ramp I've been working on llms for
four years which
is
well which is uh kind of a long time I
guess uh in LM land everything started
happening really when chat GPD came out
um so I was trying to build what people
would Now call an AI agent company back
then we were just doing customer support
we're trying to make our chat bot
smarter we're trying to figure out what
what models to use to or what tech to
use to get them to respond to customers
better and we were messing with gpd2 on
BT and models were so frustratingly
stupid and context windows were small
and they were not very smart reasoning
and it was just incredibly annoying and
we just wrote lots of code around these
models to get them to work at least
somewhat
reliably and along the way as models got
smarter this kind of had to delete more
of that code and this ended up seeing a
lot of patterns in what what code needs
to get deleted how to build agents in
what ways that will scale with more
intelligence and clearly we're going to
continue to get a lot more intelligence
and I just wanted to uh maybe talk about
a single idea throughout the talk uh
through various examples uh we we'll do
some uh some uh setting but I'll also
have a bunch of demos to kind of like
drive home the point and maybe it can
convince you guys that uh there's a
certain way of building agents that's
slightly better than other
ways I also built a structur extraction
Library called Json former um I think it
was the first one I don't I'm not fully
sure but timing wise it was before all
the other major ones um and that was
also scaffolding around a model models
were too stupid to up with Json and we
were just really begging it pleading
pleading it and forcing it to uh in ways
that we want it to
be so as I said earlier just have a one
core agenda item here which is want to
convey one idea uh we'll start off all
of you probably read the essay bit or
lesson just quickly go through what it
is uh we'll go through a production
agent we have at ramp and how it works
and three different ways of architecting
it and then I have a demo that to really
push maybe how we all think about how
software and backends and things will
work in the
future so very simply the idea is just
that systems that scale with compute
beat systems that don't so there's two
systems and uh without any effort the
the system one of the systems can just
think more or use more compute in some
way that system tends to be systems that
are rigid and fixed and just
deterministic so from that idea it's
pretty clear like if you're Building
Systems you might as well build systems
that improve with more compute and this
this seems pretty obvious like obvious
conclusion from the B lesson taking it a
step further why is this true it's
because exponentials are rare like they
just don't exist most things in the
world aren't exponential so when you
find one you just should hop on strap on
just take the free pass and go for the
right and probably shouldn't try too
hard and there's a lot of examples from
history that um to kind of reflect this
so for for chess and go and computer
vision Atari games like people have
tried to build lots of systems and
written a lot of code and my way of
thinking about rigid systems just like
spending a lot of time grinding weekends
and writing very clever software well
abstracted uh maybe trying to synthesize
human reasoning and thought process into
features and then using them in clever
ways and trying to approximate how a
human would
think and if you actually fix the amount
of compute that approach will win but if
you just turns out if you end up scaling
out how much search you're doing the
general method always ends up winning
even uh like in all these cases so Atari
go and computer
vision a little bit about ramp so ramp
is a finance platform that helps
businesses manage expenses payments
procurement travel bookkeeping more
efficiently and we have a ton of AI
across the product so automate a lot of
boring stuff the finance teams do and
employees do with uh submitting expense
reports and booking your flights and
hotels and uh submitting reimbursements
all that and so a lot of the work behind
the scenes is just we're interacting
with other systems um and helping like
Legacy systems and helping employees get
their work done
faster so let's actually talk through
one of the systems we have today at ramp
and um maybe some talk through the
different versions of the system and how
it evolved over
time so we're going to talk about
something called a switching report it's
very simple agent all it needs to do
it's taking a CSV a CSV arbitrary format
so the schema could be seriously
anything from the internet and we want
these csvs to come from third party card
providers so when people on board to
ramp we want to give them a nice
checklist and say hey here are all the
transactions you have on other platforms
and we want help you move them over and
the more transactions come on ramp the
more we can help you and the more you'll
use our software and more everyone
benefits and so the switching reports
just really a checklist but to read
people's CSV transactions we need to
understand those and other platforms
have all these kinds of crazy
schemas and so the the description of
the problem we have here is just for an
arbitrary arbitrary like CSV how can we
support um parsing it and then into some
format that we we understand
so let's just start with the the simple
approach right is like let's just take
the 50 most common third party card
vendors um and just manually write code
for all of them now obviously like this
this will just work it is some work not
a lot of work but you still have to
maybe go to 50 different platforms and
download their csvs see what schemas
they have and then write code maybe if
they decide one day they change their
format your thing will break but that's
okay you'll get page and you can wake up
and go fix it
so let's maybe introduce some LMS in
here so from the over engineered code
where you ended up writing 100,000 lines
maybe we don't we don't we want a more
General system so let's introduce a
little bit of LM a little bit of AI in
here and so in the deterministic flow
let's maybe add some or just like
scripting In classical scripting land
let's add some more um call to open AI
or you have an embedding model you want
to do semetic similarity or something
like that so then let's just take every
column in the CSV that comes in let's
try to classify what kind of column it
is is it a date is it a transaction uh
is it a transaction amount is it a
merchant name or is it the uh users's
name and then we map it on and then we
probably could uh end up in a schema
that we're happy with again most of the
compute is running in classical land
some of it is running in fuzzy llm land
but this is somewhat looking like a more
General
system let's go maybe a different
approach when like we just go all the
way through let's just say we're just
going to literally give the CSV to LM
and say you have a code interpreter so
you can write whatever code you want
pandas or all the faster rust based ones
um you have all these python packages um
you're allowed to look at the head of
the CSV the tail whichever rows you want
um and then I just want you to give me a
CSV uh with this specific format here's
a unit test here's a verifier that you
can use to tell if it's working or not
turns out this approach actually doesn't
work like we tried it um if you only run
it once but instead if you run it 50
times in parallel it's actually very
likely that it works really well and
generalizes across a ton of different
formats the amount of compute here is
actually probably like what is that
number 10,000 times more than the the
first approach we came up with but again
like what is truly scarce in the world
is engineer time maybe not for not in a
while but at least today and we'd rather
have a system that works really well and
even with a 10,000 times more compute it
will probably cost less than a dollar
and every transaction that switched over
every fail CSV will cost ramp way more
money than whatever money we spend on
this exact this exact
architecture so this is a very specific
uh example it's like how does this apply
to the agents that we all build and
maybe the systems we're all working on
turns out something like this actually
generalizes so if you look at three
approaches and let's assume like The
Black Arrow is just classical compute
and then the blue arrows are fuzzy lands
so it goes into neuron net and all all
sort of weird matric multiplication
happens and we're in latent space and
gets all alien intelligency and then
comes back to a classical land first
approach there was no AI we just wrote
code and it just worked mostly the
constrainted agent so the second
approach we broke into fuzzy land from
classic land when when we decided we
wanted similarity scores or something
like that and then the third approach is
actually flipped where the llm decides
it needs to go into classical l so it
write some code write some pandas or uh
python code and it decides to break in
into this classical land when it needs
to but most of the computer is
fuzzy actually this is maybe not the
most accurate graph like because I
propos that we run it 50 times it more
so looks like this but if you look at a
back end in general they're all request
response so some sort of message is
going in it's like a post request or get
or update or read any sort of credit
operation and we're really just asking
the back end to take this piece of
information do whatever you must with it
run out whatever mutations you want and
return me a
response and almost all systems we've
built so far as like Humanity I guess
like look like the first one but more
people are using open AI open AI makes
billions of dollars and probably a lot
of the systems that use them look like
number two where just regular uh
programming languages are calling into
open AI servers and we're running some
fuzzy
compute what we're seeing in like more
and more parts of the ram codebase we're
moving to the third approach because it
just tends to work well because all the
blue arrows if you did nothing it Absol
absolutely nothing we all went to
vacation for the next year the big labs
are still working and spending billions
of dollars making those models better so
the blue arrows will get better and so
how much blue arrow you're using in your
code base actually will help directly
your company without much effort from
your end so this is what I was saying is
like the bit or lesson is just so
powerful and exponential Trends are so
powerful that you can just hitch hitch
the
ride let's um let's take this idea like
further um let's actually like go all
the way like something something
crazy um on the left you'll see a
traditional web app so usually the way
it works is you open um
gmail.com and some uh static file server
and Google sending you bunch of
JavaScript HTML and CSS your browser
renders that um and shows you some nice
UI nice HTML that's user friendly maybe
you see some emails maybe you click on
one of them um the friend end makes a
request to the back end the back ask the
friend end friend end asks the back end
give me the content for email and
whatever ID it is and then the back in
hits database and gives you the result
and maybe they use cod genen maybe they
use all the Coden tools available to
make Gmail so that that was probably the
LM only worked when the software
engineer was writing the code but once
the code is written and it's like pushed
to production it's just classical
compute and on the right I'm actually
proposing a different model which is the
back end is the LM it's not Cen it's
this LM is doing the execution it is the
back end so the LM has access to tools
like coder interpreter and potentially
has access to um through that making
request Network requests and also has an
access to uh DB
so I have a mail client actually that
works with this principal and this is my
test email so if y'all want to see any
emails you sent to me in a minute or so
you can send me an email but please be
nice
all right I think um it's probably
enough
time so I'm going to go
over so we have this email client I mean
we still have some regular JavaScript to
hook into the LM hook the LM into the
browser but when I do log in I'm going
to use my email is just showing you
[Music]
what oh it's
probably okay we're good we're good all
right we're
saved I
think thankfully I have a room full of
Engineers
so there's a dot but the reason it's so
slow is because when I open this page
and log into Gmail the Gmail token is
actually being sent to an llm we're
saying literally this is a LM chat
session what we're we're seeing on the
screen is like hey LM you're you're
actually simulating a Gmail client you
have access to Oh all the emails you
have access to um rahul's Gmail token
and aord interpreter and so just render
some UI based on uh what you think is
reasonable for the homepage for Gmail
client and so looks like it decided to
render his markdown uh I think we
actually tell it to render his markdown
and it's rendering all the emails that a
bunch of people sent me from here so it
looks like it says uh hello from
California so I'm going to click on that
when I click on that we're actually not
running um any like backend calls or
anything like that we're just telling
the LM the user clicked on that piece of
text in this case it was hello from
California and the ID number so the LM
now has the information on what the user
clicked on and it has the chance to
render the page much like a web
framework would so again it goes back it
probably hits uh a get request for that
specific email and pulls the
body what is this agent going to do I'm
watching you live so the LM just decided
this is the appropriate UI for a Gmail
client also I have other features the LM
thought was reasonable so looks like I
could mark it as unread or or delete the
email if I want to uh maybe I'll delete
it because it's not that good of an
email I'm sorry
it is very slow because we're doing a
lot but wanted to push you in this
direction because this kind of software
barely
works
dang I guess not um also I clicked on it
and now the LM is trying to do something
with me clicking on it anyway um this
kind of software barely works today and
it doesn't mean it w won't work in the
future uh but exponential trends like
things might just like this might just
take off um so just wanted to push you
all to think in this direction um yeah
Will software more software look like
this I don't know we'll see thank you
[Music]